vigilance accrue auprès des commerçants
des Yvelines en cette période de fête de
fin d'année le dispositif de sécurité a
été renforcé dans les zones commercial
lundi la Chambre de Commerce de
Versailles a réuni forces de l'ordre et
commerçants pour faire un point ensemble
constate une stabilisation d'e faits en
tout cas de fait de cambriolage dans les
commerces en revanche on a une très
légère augmentation concernant l'effet
un petit peu plus violent c'estàd les
attaques à armée Carl Pitel a été Cambri
il y a un an recett et bijou lui ont été
dérobé le choc passé il a décidé de
mieux équiper sa boutique je vais
essayer d'améliorer un peu la sécurité
bien que je l'ai déjà amélioré quand je
je me suis fait cambrioler mais là je
vais essayer d'améliorer au niveau du
commerce la police et la gendarmerie
était présent pour délivrer des conseils
en premier lieu le bon sens ne pas
mettre de la marchandise onéreuse près
des près des issu de secours délester
les caisses à maximum et changer les
horaires de passage de des convoyeurs de
fond si possible ou si on va ce so même
à la banque ne pas hésiter à changer les
horaires ainsi que les parcours un tas
de conseil tels que ceci déjà s'ils
étaient respectés à la base pourrai
supprimer bien des problèmes pour
renforcer le dispositif de sécurité la
Chambre de commerce va mettre en place
un système d'alerte par SMS les
commerçants pourront signaler chaque
incident sur un portail Web sécurisé les
autres commerçants abonnés recevront
quelques minutes plus tard une alerte
SMS avec la description Fas lancement de
l'opération prévue
début3